I'm going to tell you a story about a car built for individuals.
But the story is driven by you with actual tweets you sent to Jimmy Fallon.
Here goes.
Adina was going to someone else's wedding.
Girl, today's your lucky day.
She picked up a German hitchhiker, who came to America to study farming.
How charming.
Discussing their mutual love for sweaters, they drove past an alpaca farm.
It's the Alpacalypse!
Then they got stopped by some turtles crossing the road,...
...next to some guys with a PhD in leather.
Oh, soft!
And then they drove through a movie set in Palmdale,...
...ruining the best performance of an alien ever.
Really?
Ah, the tweets and turns of life.
You may be surprised where they can take you.
The road is full of love.
This was a story that started with you...
...because luxury always should.